l' affaire ubs est rejugé en appel
jusqu'au 24 mars à paris la plus grande
banque privée suisse avait été condamné
à payer l'amendé record de 4,5 milliards
d'euros pour démarchage illégal et
blanchiment aggravé de fraude fiscale au
détriment de l'état français
l'accusation dénonce un gigantesque
système d'évasion fiscale qui encouragé
les clients français à transférer leurs
actifs sur des groupes non déclarés en
suisse
au procès les anciens directeurs ou
cadres de la banque se défendent de
toute action illégale des arguments
réfutés par bradley birkenfeld ancien
gérant de fortune chez ubs aux états
unis en 2006 il s'est fait connaître
pour ses révélations de pratiques
frauduleuses de la banque privée
le scandale qu'il a soulevés a mené à
l'interdiction du secret bancaire suisse
en 2009 cela ne lui a pas évité une
condamnation à trente mois de prison
pour fraude fiscale toujours en 2009
mais il a ensuite reçu 104 millions de
dollars du fisc américain pour ses
confessions
pour lui la banque suisse en serait
finalement tirer à bon compte aux états
unis en échappant au procès et on est
copains que d'une faible amende
grâce à ses appuis politiques barack
obama a reçu de l'argent du ps pour sa
campagne
hillary clinton a reçu de l'argent pour
sa fondation de la part du ps et du
gouvernement suisse et bill clinton a
signé des contrats pour des conférences
pour ubs pour des millions de dollars
alors vous pensez qu'ils vont se ranger
de quel côté ubs ou pourra dire qu'elle
fait là hillary clinton avait beaucoup
de donneurs parce que je connais
beaucoup de clients qui donnait pour sa
campagne depuis la suisse donc c'est une
corruption supplémentaires qui explique
pourquoi ils n'ont pas voulu poursuivre
ubs en bonne et due forme et documents
internes à l'appui il livre son
interprétation de la stratégie mondiale
de la banque suisse il y avait un
programme d'hier et ferrals qui
reportait les clients du marché onshore
soit légale au marché offshore de suisse
pourquoi 1 parce que leur jeu est resté
plus longtemps
2 il facturait des frais plus important
3 il pensait pouvoir leur assurer le
secret je sais cela car les banquiers
recevez un bonus lors ce qui se passe
c'est que vous rémunérer des banquiers
ce qui est du blanchiment d'argent en
réalité car vous participez à un système
d'évasion fiscale ce qui mène au
blanchiment d'argent et à d'autres actes
délictueux ubs suisse serait t'il aussi
l'aspirateur du bs france parmi les
ténors du barreau qui défendent la
banque denis chemla à proposer cette
même hypothèse pour mieux la réfuter
patrick de faille est l'ancien numéro 2
du ps france s'est aussitôt défendu de
toute stratégie pour siphonner les
comptes hexagonaux selon lui sa mission
était de développer la jeune banque
française stéphanie gibeau ancien chargé
du marketing du bs france entre 1999 et
finalement licencié par la banque en
2012 conteste en alimentant le service
national des douanes judiciaires en 2011
et 2012 avec des documents qui lui a été
demandé de faire fuiter
la lanceuse d' alerte a fourni la
matière de l'accusation
aujourd'hui abandonnée de tous y compris
de l'état français qu'elle a abondamment
servi
elle n'est pas citée à comparaître à
l'audience aucun lanceur d' alerte à la
barre stéphanie gibault a son avis sur
la question
ubs gère les fortunes de tous nos
dirigeants économiques financiers
médiatiques politiques partout dans le
monde
ici un cru et là j'en suis une témoins
privilégiés puisque pendant douze ans
j'ai organisé des centaines d'événements
pour la banque où toutes les familles
les plus fortunées de france étaient
présentes soit des gens du show business
des sportifs de haut niveau des hommes
politiques bien évidemment des juges
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas le
nom affiché de ces personnes qui
fraudent pourquoi est-ce que tout est
caché
pourquoi est ce que la justice française
ne peut pas exploiter cette liste
pourquoi des gens comme moi justement
sont dans la situation qu'on vienne
expliquer c'est à dire ne pas être
entendu par la justice alors que là pour
le coup serait le témoin clé de cette
justice puisque j'ai travaillé pour
l'état français pendant plus d'un an
alors qui sont ces fameux nom des
détenteurs de comptes
le journaliste antoine peillon et le
lanceur d'alerté nicolas forissier
ancien responsable d'audit de la banque
ubs
les évoque dans un entretien exclusif
mis en ligne le 17 mars
nicolas forissier a visé entre autres
les comptes ubs de l'héritière de
l'oréal liliane
bettencourt il explique qu'il avait
repéré entre fin 2005 et 2007 en pleine
campagne présidentielle de nicolas
sarkozy
des opérations pour 20 millions d'euros
ne faisant l'objet d'aucune vérification
légale en termes de lutte contre le
blanchiment
à partir de novembre 2017 on retrouve
d'ailleurs aux manettes de la gestion de
fortune de liliane bettencourt patrick
de maistre et florence woerth la femme
d'eric woerth
le trésorier de l'ump et ministre du
budget de nicolas sarkozy dès 2009
l'aide des séries alors sous la
direction de bernard squarcini reçoit
des notes sur la découverte d'un système
d'évasion fiscale au sein du bes et
l'incroyable se produit nicolas
forissier et placés sous surveillance et
un agent en enquêtant sur ubs avait des
séries et sommé d'arrêter les notes sur
la fraude ne sont même pas transmises au
procureur un véritable scandale que
dénonce en 2013 un collectif d'officiers
delà des séries dans un rapport pourquoi
après avoir découvert cette infraction
pénale
la sous-direction cas de la dessert il
ne l'at-elle pas dénoncés au procureur
de la république
pourquoi la sous-direction cas at elle a
axé son travail de surveillance sur les
cadres de l'ubs et s qui dénonçait le
système de fraude plutôt que sur ce qui
était à l'origine du système
le lanceur d'alert pense que le service
de renseignement voulait savoir s'il
détenait la preuve ultime d'un
financement de la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy
deux journalistes d'investigation
antoine peillon qui a enquêté des années
sur ubs livre son hypothèse certains
gros clients auraient été des financeurs
occulte de campagne électorale de
grandes personnalités politiques
françaises politique qui était au
pouvoir et aurait instrumentalisé les
services de renseignements intérieurs
pour protéger l'évasion fiscale de ces
grands donateurs
il n'y a pas de preuve formelle mais de
nombreux documents et indices
concordants
on se souvient qu'en 2012 eric woerth
avait été soupçonné d'avoir recueilli
des dizaines de milliers d'euros en
liquide provenant de liliane bettencourt
mise en examen pour trafic d'influencé
passif et recel
il a bénéficié d'un non lieu en 2015 sa
connaissance de l'origine des fonds et
de la vulnérabilité de madame
bettencourt n'avait pas pu être démontré
rt français demande
des interviews à plusieurs avocats du bs
qui ont tous décliné ou n'ont pas donné
suite aux sollicitations
ce retour de l' affaire ubs dans
l'actualité sera-t-il l'occasion de
mettre en lumière un nouveau scandale
d'état